David Boder: [In English] Paris, August the 22nd 1946, at the headquarters of the Joint, American Joint Distribution Committee. The interviewee is Miss Irena Rosenwasser. Also...and she prefers to speak German although her English is...seems to be rather satisfactory.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Fräulein Rosenwasser, wollen Sie uns sagen, von wo sind Sie?
Irena Rosenwasser: Aus Ungarn.
David Boder: Sie sind aus Ungarn. Also, Sie wollen, Sie haben gesagt, Sie wollen nach Amerika gehen und Sie gehören zu der ungarischen Quote, nicht wahr?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Und sie haben einen Onkel in Los Angeles. Und wir heißt der?
Irena Rosenwasser: Rabbi Goldberger.
David Boder: Ja. Sie müssen aber sprechen, wenn Sie den Kopf bewegen, Television [lacht etwas] haben wir noch nicht, nicht wahr! [lacht] Es ist der Rabbiner Dr. Goldberger, nicht wahr?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Also nun, Fräulein Goldwasser, wollen Sie mir sagen, wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg anfing, wo hat Sie der Krieg getroffen? Sprechen Sie jetzt lauter.
Irena Rosenwasser: Also ich war zu Hause bis zum Jahre vier und vierzig (44).
David Boder: Wo ist das: zu Hause?
Irena Rosenwasser: In Ungarn, in Kisvarda.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: In der Stadt Kisvarda—mit meinen Eltern und meiner ganzen Familie.
David Boder: Wollen Sie mir sagen, wie viele Menschen in Ihrer Familie waren.
Irena Rosenwasser: Sechs Kinder...
David Boder: Ja und ihr Vater?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und die Eltern.
David Boder: Ihr Vater und ihre Mutter?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Und sechs (6) Kinder.
David Boder: Und welches Kind sind Sie? Das Älteste oder welches?
Irena Rosenwasser: Mein Bruder ist der Älteste, nachher komm ich.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann die anderen Kinder sind wie alt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die waren kleiner.
David Boder: Was heißt, die waren...?
Irena Rosenwasser: Acht (8) Jahre, zehn (10) Jahre, siebzehn (17) und zwanzig (20) Jahre alt.
David Boder: Aha. Und Sie waren schon über zwanzig (20) dann?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Nun also, Sie lebten in Ungarn und was hat da passiert, als der Krieg anfing?
Irena Rosenwasser: Wenn der Krieg anfing, war überhaupt nichts Schlimmes für die Juden.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Nur, wenn die Deutschen herein gekommen sind in vier und vierzig (44) hat man konzentriert die Juden in verschiedenen Ghettos und von den Ghettos hat man sie deportiert.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie mir erzählen, was Ihnen persönlich passiert hat und in Ihrer Stadt—was Sie selbst gesehen und selbst durchgemacht haben. Also wir hat das angefangen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Also die Juden durften nicht ihre Häuser verlassen. Man hat alle Namen aufgeschrieben, man hat eine Liste gemacht von die Kinder und von die Geschäfte und Vermögen. Und die Juden mussten alles abgeben und ins Ghetto konnten sie nur ungefähr fünfzig (50) Kilo mitnehmen.
David Boder: Aha. Wann und wie hat das passiert? Wie hat man das annonciert, dass sie haben müssen ins Ghetto gehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Gendarmerie hat das annonciert.
David Boder: Ja und können Sie sich erinnern in welchem Monat das war?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, es war im Mai vier und vierzig (44)—im Mai.
David Boder: Also was haben die gesagt? Man muss sich...?
Irena Rosenwasser: Vorher waren immer jüdische Gesetze gegen die Juden.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Man hat schon ihnen alles weg genommen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Zum Beispiel: die Felder und...
David Boder: Ja. Was war das Geschäft Ihrer Eltern?
Irena Rosenwasser: Konfektion.
David Boder: Aha, sie hatten ein Konfektionsgeschäft.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie hat man das Geschäft weg genommen? Wie hat man...
Irena Rosenwasser: Zugesperrt. Ausgeräumt dann alles und zugesperrt...und den Schlüssel haben die gehabt.
David Boder: Und die Sachen sind im Geschäft geblieben?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Und wissen Sie, was nachher damit passiert ist?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das nicht. Ich denke sie haben...die Deutschen haben alles mitgenommen./
David Boder: Aha. Nun die haben einfach ihr Geschäft zugesperrt. Haben die das Geld verlangt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Alles, ja. Die Kasse, die volle Kasse und die Ware.
David Boder: Aha. Und das haben sie alles zu genommen und dann haben sie Ihnen gesagt, was sollen Sie tun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Dass wir müssen in die Häuser...in die Häuser bleiben.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und es waren täglich zwei (2) oder drei (3) Stunden frei, da können wir etwas besorgen wie Lebensmittel...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und dann haben sie nach einer Woche gesagt, wir werden alle konzentriert werden. Es waren einige Häuser für die Juden.
David Boder: Ja, bestimmt.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . bestimmt. Und so sind wir mit einem Wagen ins Ghetto gekommen.
David Boder: Wie heißt die Stadt, wo Sie gewohnt haben, nochmal?
Irena Rosenwasser: Kisvarda.
David Boder: Wie viele Leute lebten dort im Ganzen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sechzehn tausend (16).
David Boder: Im Ganzen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie viele Juden ungefähr waren dort?
Irena Rosenwasser: Juden waren zwei tausend (2000) , aber die ganze Gegend war konzentriert in Kisvarda. Also wir waren dort im Ghetto ungefähr sechs tausend (6000) Juden.
David Boder: Aha, von der Umgebung haben Sie auch die Juden...[beide sprechen]
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, das war ein Konzentrationsort Kisvarda.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann wie hat man das Ghetto gemacht, wie war das gemacht?
Irena Rosenwasser: Zwei Gassen waren dafür bestimmt, mit große Häuser. Alles war ausgeleert, die Christen mussten weggehen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und wir haben das bekommen. In einem Zimmer waren wir ungefähr zwölf (12) bis zwanzig (20) Leute.
David Boder: In einem Zimmer!!!!!
Irena Rosenwasser: In einem Zimmer, ja,...Kinder mit Männer und Frauen zusammen.
David Boder: Na, wie hat man da geschlafen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Auf dem Boden gelegen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . keine Betten, gar keine Möbel waren drinnen—gar nichts. Kein Sessel, gar nichts—das war strengstens verboten.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und wir haben Küche gemacht...
David Boder: Wo?
Irena Rosenwasser: Im Schulhaus—also auf der Strasse, es war ein Platz dort...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: im Schulplatz...
Irena Rosenwasser: Dort haben sie gebaut diese...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: dort haben sie die großen, großen Küchen aufgebaut, die Juden.
David Boder: [In English] There is a break in the spool, there is a break in the spool, which has to be fixed after rewinding.
David Boder: [In German] Also wir waren dabei, Frau...oder Fräulein Rosenwasser, wir waren dabei, dass Sie sagten, sie mussten ins Ghetto gehen. Sie waren 12 oder 10 Personen in einem Zimmer, Männer, Frauen und Kinder. Und man hat ihr Eigentum weg genommen und sie sagen, man hat das Geld weg genommen. Was sonst haben Sie aufgeben müssen? Sie sagten etwas von Schmuck, nun...
Irena Rosenwasser: Von Schmuck...Alles, alle was wertvolle...alle wertvollen Sachen mussten wir abgeben; nur Lebensmittel und ein paar Kleider durften wir mitnehmen.
David Boder: Haben Sie etwas von ihrem Geld versteckt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein wir haben gar nichts versteckt. Fast täglich sind sie gekommen—die Polizei—und haben die Juden weg geführt und haben sie schrecklich geschlagen.
David Boder: Im Ghetto schon, von dem Ghetto?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, von Ghetto, wo sie haben ihr Geld versteckt und ihr Vermögen. Einige haben sie tot geschlagen...
David Boder: Ja. Hat so etwas, so etwas Ähnliches Ihrer Familie passiert?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein.
David Boder: Warum hat man Ihnen geglaubt, dass sie alles abgegeben haben?
Irena Rosenwasser: Weil wir waren nicht so reiche Leut.
David Boder: Ah, sie waren nicht reiche Leut vom Anfang. Also...nun...was hat nach dem passiert?
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir waren...
David Boder: Was hat man getan, um zu leben im Ghetto?
Irena Rosenwasser: Überhaupt nichts—wir haben nur organisiert Juden, was wir könnten machen. Es waren einige Ärzte dort...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und Polizei, jüdische Polizei, aber von außerhalb ist keine Hilfe gekommen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Überhaupt nichts. Die Wehrmacht war eben in der Stadt, die deutsche Wehrmacht und einige SS Leute.
David Boder: Aha...nun und so...
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir haben gedacht wir bleiben hier, aber Ende des Monats sind Nachrichten gekommen, dass wir müssen das Ghetto verlassen. In zwei (2) Transporten hat man uns zum Bahnhof geführt. Dort hat man wieder alles kontrolliert und weg genommen alles [lacht etwas] und nachher waren wir sieben und siebzig Leute in einen Viehwagen eingesperrt.
David Boder: Warum nennen Sie es einen Viehwagen? Das waren Frachtwagen oder war das ein richtige Viehwagen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Für Pferde war es.
David Boder: Woher wissen Sie das?
Irena Rosenwasser: Es ist drauf gestanden.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, so ein deutscher Wagon war das für vierzig (40) Pferde oder dreißig (30). Ich weiß das nicht mehr so genau. Und...
David Boder: Oh ja. Also...?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und das war plombiert.
David Boder: Ja. Und wie viele Leute waren Sie da?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sieben und siebzig (77) Leute.
David Boder: Und wer hat das gezählt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Also die Gendarmerie—wie wir sind eingestiegen hat man die Leute gezählt—niemand soll fehlen.
David Boder: Aha und dann?
Irena Rosenwasser: Da war ein großer Appellplatz und man hat gezählt die Leute vor.
David Boder: Ja. Die Deutschen haben das genannt „Appell“, das heißt die Leute zählen und aufrufen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Und so weiter. Nun und so weiter und, hm,...und, hm,...waren Sie—die ganze Familie zusammen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, im Wagon waren wir noch zusammen.
David Boder: Im Wagon...im Wagon waren Sie zusammen, ja?
Irena Rosenwasser: Bis Auschwitz...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . sind wir ungefähr drei (3) Tage gefahren—ohne Luft, ohne Wasser und mit zwei (2) Toten.
David Boder: Wieso? Man hat die Toten nicht raus genommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: No, nein.
David Boder: Sie sagen ohne Luft und ohne Wasser. Waren da keine Fenster im Wagen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war plombiert , also einige Löcher waren trotzdem, aber das war nicht genug [beide sprechen].
David Boder: Ja. Und...
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber das war nicht genug.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, war dort eine Toilette?
Irena Rosenwasser: Überhaupt nicht einer.
David Boder: Nicht einer; und wie haben die Leute dann ihre...sich befriedigt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Also einen Vorhang hat man gemacht.
David Boder: Man hat gemacht einen Vorhang, ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, und wann hat man das heraus geworfen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nur bei der Ankunft.
David Boder: Nur bei der Ankunft. So die Luft war sehr schlecht?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sehr schlecht, darum sind Zwei (2) gestorben, zwei (2) schwächere Leute.
David Boder: Männer oder Frauen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ein alter Mann und eine jüngere Frau.
David Boder: Alright, nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir sind angekommen in Auschwitz,...aber der Weg war sehr schlimm, weil immer sind SS heraus gekommen, die haben geöffnet die Wagons bei einigen Stationen und haben wieder verlangt Schmuck oder jemand hat vielleicht noch was Geld mit gebracht—versteckt, die sind mit Gewehr heraus gekommen und haben verlangt weiße Uhr...Uhren, Toilet...Toiletstücke...
David Boder: Uhren?
Irena Rosenwasser: und Goldschmuck...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und so haben sie wieder geraubt.
Irena Rosenwasser: Dann sind wir ungefähr um 12 Uhr in der Nacht angekommen in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Und wie viele Tage sind sie gefahren?
Irena Rosenwasser: Zwei ein halb (2 ½ ), drei (3) Tage ungefähr.
David Boder: Ja und dann sind Sie in Auschwitz angekommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Freitag abends war es, da sind wir angekommen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . am Bahnhof von Auschwitz. Wir mussten warten zwei (2), drei (3 ) Stunden und nachher haben sie geöffnet die Wagons und sind wir ausgestiegen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie haben sofort gesagt, wir mussten alle Bagage, alles im Wagon lassen, wir werden es morgen bekommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Dann hat man die Selektion angefangen. Wir wussten natürlich nicht, was das bedeutet.
Irena Rosenwasser: Meine Mutter mit...mit meinen zwei (2) Geschwistern hat man auf die rechte Seite gestellt...
David Boder: Waren das Schwestern oder Brüder?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Zwei (2) Schwestern?
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und ich...
David Boder: Wie alt waren die Mädchen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Acht (8) und zehn (10) Jahre alt.
David Boder: Ja, die Mutter mit dem zwei Kindern.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, meine Mutter war acht und vierzig (48).
David Boder: Ja...und?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und meine Brüder extra, separat. Die Männer wurden sofort...
David Boder: Und Ihr Vater?
Irena Rosenwasser: Der Vater auch...
David Boder: Mit den Brüdern?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Und Sie wieder...
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, ich wieder, weil ich war...also die jüngeren Leute waren wieder separat gestellt.
David Boder: Ja...und?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und dann habe ich sie nie mehr gesehen [weint].
David Boder: Wen haben Sie nie mehr gesehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Jemand von meiner Familie.
David Boder: Ihre Brüder auch nicht?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, niemanden. Mein Bruder—einer—wir waren doch sechs Kinder.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ein Bruder ist nicht mit uns gekommen.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Also der ist am Leben geblieben.
David Boder: Wie alt er, war der?
Irena Rosenwasser: Er ist sechs und zwanzig (26)—acht und zwanzig (28) ist er jetzt.
David Boder: War er verheiratet?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein.
David Boder: Und wieso ist er zurück geblieben?
Irena Rosenwasser: Also, er ist alleine vom Ghetto geflohen.
David Boder: Er ist weg gerannt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, er ist weg gelaufen. Man hat ihn überall gesucht. Er hat sich versteckt und später ist er dann mit Mühe und Not nach Budapest gekommen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und von Budapest hat man ihn nach Belgien getragen.
David Boder: Geschickt.
Irena Rosenwasser: Nach Belgien geschickt und von Belgien—er war befreit—ist er nach der Schweiz gekommen und von der Schweiz nach Palästina. Dort ist er momentan und er lebt in Palästina.
David Boder: Ist er nach Palästina illegal gekommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, legal.
David Boder: Er hat eine Bewilligung...
Irena Rosenwasser: Mit dem letzten Transport
David Boder: Aha. Nun...und die
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Anderen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . die zwei (2) Jüngeren...
David Boder: Haben Sie ihn in Belgien gesehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen.
David Boder: Sie haben ihn nicht gesehen seit Anfang des Krieges?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich habe ihn überhaupt nicht gesehen.
David Boder: Ja. Und die zwei (2) Jüngeren?
Irena Rosenwasser: Von denen habe ich gehört. Sie waren in Auschwitz, in einem anderen Lager, weil in Auschwitz waren doch sämtliche, viele Lager...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und später hat man sie mit einem Transport weg geschickt und nie mehr hat man sie gesehen.
David Boder: Und ihren Vater und Mutter?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich habe gar nichts gehört. Die waren schon leider am Bahnhof [unverständlich], weil neben dem Bahnhof waren gleich zwei (2) Krematorien. Sofort hat man die Leute, hat man ihnen gesagt, sie gehen baden.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und ich habe das Krematorium selbst gesehen, weil wenn die Russen sind gekommen immer näher und näher, die haben zerstört die Krematorien. Ich habe genau gesehen, es war aufgeschrieben „Zum Baderaum“—„Zur Desinfektion“, so hat man die armen Leute herein geführt...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und...
David Boder: Sie sind nicht mehr heraus gekommen.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . nicht mehr heraus—verbrannt.
David Boder: Nun und was...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und die Kinder...das auch, weil der Herr Mengele, der Arzt vom Lager hat gesagt, er will keine Kinder sehen.
David Boder: Oh, der Arzt vom Lager hat gesagt...
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: . . . er will keine Kinder sehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Er will keine Kinder sehen, nur Arbeiter. Das ist ein Arbeitslager und nicht für Kinder und...
David Boder: Der Arzt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, der Arzt!
David Boder: Was war sein Name?
Irena Rosenwasser: Mengele.
David Boder: Mengele. Wissen Sie nicht, was mit ihm passiert ist?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ein Deutscher. Oh doch, ich habe gehört einmal, man hat ihn gefangen.
David Boder: Man hat ihn gefangen, ja?
Irena Rosenwasser: Man hat ihn gefunden
David Boder: Nun...also...und dann, was hat Ihnen passiert?
Irena Rosenwasser: Also eine ganze Nacht war ich in der Bad, im Bad...
David Boder: Sie haben die Krematorien an der Station gesehen? Haben die Schornsteine geraucht?
Irena Rosenwasser: Gebannt—ein großes Feuer von weitem—Lärm und Geschrei war dort. Wir wussten überhaupt nicht was passiert. Und der Rauch, das war furchtbar, das können wir nicht beschreiben.
David Boder: Ist der Rauch von dem Schornstein gekommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja. Und außerhalb waren auch große Feuer immer.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Das hat man doch immer gesehen vom Lager—die Krematorien. Die waren doch nicht weit, das...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . das haben wir Tag und Nacht gesehen.
David Boder: Was? Das...das...
Irena Rosenwasser: Es hat immer gebrannt.
David Boder: Und was außerhalb der Krematorien haben draußen gebrannt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Es waren außerhalb...große, weil es war zu wenig...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . weil man konnte nur ungefähr tausend Leute verbrennen. Außerhalb hat man große Graben gemacht und man hat die Leute erst vergast und nachher in diese Gräber herein gelegt und mit Petroleum oder so etwas angezündet.
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber außerhalb hat es gebrannt...
David Boder: Und man hat den Rauch gesehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Oh, immer. Und es war ein sehr, sehr großes Feuer. Es war so hoch—zum Himmel war es—unaufhörlich.
David Boder: Oh.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wenn die Transporte sind gekommen...
David Boder: Die Häftlinge haben gewusst, was da vorgeht?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Was wollten Sie über die Transporte sagen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Transporte sind immer gekommen von Ungarn...weiter und weiter..., weil in Ungarn waren doch ein (1) Millionen Juden. Und man hat außerhalb Budapest...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . alle in Konzentrationslager gebracht und hauptsächlich nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Außerhalb von Budapest...und in Budapest...[unverständlich—beide sprechen]...
Irena Rosenwasser: Auch in Budapest haben sie gefangen sehr viele Leute auf der Strasse, aber Einige haben sich doch trotzdem gerettet.
David Boder: Ja, und zwischen denen war Ihr älterer Bruder?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja,...mein Bruder.
David Boder: Ja. Wann haben Sie zum ersten Mal von Ihrem Bruder gehört?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich habe von England einen Brief erhalten, von einer Frau—verheiratet, die hat mich verständigt. Ich war in Bergen-Belsen nach der Befreiung.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war eine große Freude für mich.
David Boder: Sie haben ihn gesehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein.
David Boder: Aha. Nun...
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir waren im Bad die ganze Nacht.
David Boder: Im Bad?
Irena Rosenwasser: Im Bad. Also zuerst hat man unsere Haare abgeschnitten und alle seine Kleidungsstücke weggenommen und ohne Strümpfe. Ein Hemd, ein schlechtes Kleid haben wir bekommen, hölzerne Schuhe...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war sehr kalt, der Platz ist doch in Polonia...in Polen.
David Boder: In Polen, ja...
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war...
David Boder: In welchem Monat war es?
Irena Rosenwasser: Im Mai.
David Boder: Im Mai, aber es war kalt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Hauptsächlich in der Nacht, da war es schrecklich. Dann hat man uns ungefähr um 6 Uhr heraus geschmissen und hat man uns gezählt...
David Boder: Was heißt heraus geschmissen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Immer hat man uns geschlagen, von erster Minute an hat man die Leute geschlagen.
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
Irena Rosenwasser: Erstens einmal waren das SS Männer—Soldaten und SS Frauen mit große Stöcke. „Schneller, schneller, raus gehen, lauf.“ Und nachher waren es auch jüdische Leute.
David Boder: Capos, was sie nennen.?
Irena Rosenwasser: Capos, ja. Wo arbeiten die Frauen, eine Slowakin war da zum Beispiel. Die hat uns gesagt: „Damen—ihr werdet nie mehr Damen sein“. Damit hat sie uns empfangen und hat gelacht dazu.
David Boder: So [unverständlich—beide sprechen].
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und sehr schlechte Kleiderstücke haben wir bekommen—aus Seiden.
David Boder: Aus was?
Irena Rosenwasser: Aus Seiden.
David Boder: Was soll das heißen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Aus Seiden war das Kleid, das Material war Seide. Schlechte, zerrissene Kleider.
David Boder: Seide?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja. Und dann sind wir endlich in das Lager herein gekommen.
David Boder: Was ist Seiden, Baumwolle, meinen Sie?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein—Seide!
David Boder: Seide—silk?
Irena Rosenwasser: Hier.
David Boder: Und woher haben sie das bekommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Leute haben Pakete mit gebracht nach Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ach ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Bis fünfzig (50) Kilo dürften wir mitnehmen...und das hat man doch alles weg genommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Da hat man die beste Wäsch aussortiert und die hat man nach Deutschland geschickt und uns hat man gegeben die ganz schlechte und zerrissene...[unverständlich—beide sprechen]
David Boder: Ja, also das waren nicht ihre eigenen Sachen, nicht wahr?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, überhaupt nicht!
David Boder: Ja und?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und in der Früh sind wir endlich—es hat geregnet, es war kalt und alle haben geweint, wir waren verzweifelt und furchtbar durstig, Durst haben wir gehabt...
David Boder: Ja und gab es kein Wasser?
Irena Rosenwasser: Man hat uns kein Wasser gegeben. Sie haben gesagt, es ist gefährlich zum Trinken und dass da war T...Typhus.
David Boder: Es war Typhus?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sind wir angekommen in der Früh und mussten In Zähl-Lager, sogenanntes Zähl-Lager—man hat uns beim Tor gezählt bevor die SS Leute...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und neben der Küche sind wir stehen geblieben und endlich nach zwei (2) oder drei (3) Stunden sind die Block Ältesten angekommen und haben ausgewählt dreißig (30, vierzig (40) Leute von unserem Transport. Und alle haben in ihrem Block genommen. Wir sind in Block siebzehn (17) angekommen...
David Boder: Hatten Sie schon ihre Haare abgeschnitten dann?
Irena Rosenwasser: Alles war schon ab, ja...
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Haare?
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Jüdische Häftlinge.
David Boder: Mit elektrischen Rasierapparaten?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, nein, nein, mit Schere.
David Boder: Mit Scheren?
Irena Rosenwasser: Mit Scheren oder was da war.
David Boder: Männer oder Frauen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Frauen.
David Boder: Frauen...nun...
Irena Rosenwasser: Und...ich war in Block 17.
David Boder: Hat man sie tätowiert?
Irena Rosenwasser: Später...später...
David Boder: Oh, Sie haben eine Tattoo Nummer?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Das ist ?
Irena Rosenwasser: „A“—zehntausend vier hundert ein und zwanzig—A10421.
David Boder: „A“—zehntausend vier hundert ein und zwanzig—A10421. Nimmt der Konsul diese Tattoo Nummern auf?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, aber—das ist keine Präferenz—er sagte [lacht].
David Boder: Aber er nimmt die Nummer auf?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Er schreibt sie auf?
David Boder: A zehntausend vier...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . hundert ein und zwanzig—A10421.
David Boder: ein und zwanzig (21).
Irena Rosenwasser: Abzeichen, auf der rechten habe ich.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Es hat geregnet und in den Block ist der Regen herein gefallen. Mir war sehr kalt und ich war sehr müde und konnte keinen Platz finden.
Irena Rosenwasser: Weil es waren Betten, so dreistöckig...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . aus Holz.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und in allen diese Betten schliefen ungefähr 12 Leute in einem Bett.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Natürlich wenn Einer neu ist gekommen, wollte man keinen Platz geben...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . weil das war sowieso zu eng. Die Decken waren nass vom Regen, weil der Regen ist herein gefallen...
David Boder: Wie viele Leute waren in einem Bett sagen Sie?
Irena Rosenwasser: Zehn (10), zwölf (12).
David Boder: In einem Bett?
Irena Rosenwasser: In einem Bett—ohne Decken; und wenn Einer hat eine Decke gehabt, dann hat man sie sofort gestohlen [lacht].
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Also der Block Älteste ist gekommen und hat Ordnung gemacht und ich...so habe ich auch einen Platz bekommen.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Man hat mir gegeben sofort zu essen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war ein...ich weiß nicht was das war, so wie Haferflocken, aber sehr schlecht und es hat wirklich gestunken. Ich konnte es überhaupt nicht essen. Die Anderen waren schon...sind schon vor einer Woche gekommen und die waren sehr hungrig und haben mir sofort gesagt: „Wenn Du es kannst nicht essen, dann gib es uns.“
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich habe es ihnen sofort gegeben. Zwei Tage konnte ich nicht essen. Nachher war ich auch schon sehr hungrig. Die Neuen haben überhaupt kein Brot bekommen.
David Boder: Warum?
Irena Rosenwasser: Solange sie waren nicht einregistriert.
David Boder: Oh.
Irena Rosenwasser: Das hat gedauert drei (3) Tage.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich habe ungefähr gar nichts gegessen drei (3) Tage und dann hat mir die Suppe auch geschmeckt. [lacht]...nach drei (3) Tagen.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war so aus Gerste.
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ohne Vitamine, ohne Gemüse.
David Boder: Nun und...
Irena Rosenwasser: Und täglich zwei Mal war Zähl-Appell.
David Boder: Zähl-Appell?
Irena Rosenwasser: Zähl-Appell.
David Boder: Und wie hat man das gemacht?
Irena Rosenwasser: Zähl-Appell ist, dass man hat die Leute gezählt im Lager. Im Lager C, wo ich war, waren zwei und dreißig tausend (32000) Leute. Mussten wir in der Früh bei noch dunkel aufstehen. Es war ein, hm, Ruf im Lager „Alle aufstehen, aufstehen und Kaffee holen!“
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Bitteren Kaffee haben wir bekommen, sehr wenig. Wir mussten die Kessel von der Küche schleppen...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und so hat man uns alle hinaus gejagt in den Waschraum.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Der Waschraum war ziemlich gross, aber für so viele Leute war er sehr klein. Wir mussten uns waschen ohne Handtuch, ohne Seife. Wir haben Stücke gerissen von unserem Hemd.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und damit...das war ein...
David Boder: Handtuch?
Irena Rosenwasser: ein Handtuch
David Boder: Und was haben Sie auf dem Kopf gehabt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Gar nichts, das war strengstens verboten. Kein Bettstücke haben wir gehabt, das war Sabotage, gar nichts und so sind wir gestanden da.
David Boder: Wo war das?
Irena Rosenwasser: In Auschwitz.
David Boder: Aber manche...andere...in anderen Transporten, die haben etwas bekommen für den Kopf.
Irena Rosenwasser: Bei uns war es verboten.
David Boder: Wo war das?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Nun dann...?
Irena Rosenwasser: Also im Waschraum war immer eine große Schlägerei. Der Lager Cap musste kommen, weil natürlich die Leute konnten sich nicht alle waschen—alle wollten sich zur selben Zeit waschen
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und die Leute wurden geschlagen. Und dann hta der Appell angefangen, von halb 6 ( ½ 6) hat er bis 8 gedauert oder halb neun ( ½ 9). Dort sind wir gestanden und wenn die Nummer hat gestimmt, dann war es gut. Sonst mussten wir knien noch zwei (2), drei (3) Stunden oder...
David Boder: Was heißt knien?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das ganze Lager knien.
David Boder: Auf den Knien sitzen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein. So ja, knien.
David Boder: Ja, wie in der Kirche?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja. Und die deutschen SS Frauen und Männer sind gekommen und sie haben gezählt. Manchmal haben sie sich geirrt und dann ist die Strafe für uns gekommen. Die Strafe hat bedeutet, dass wir bekommen kein Brot oder Zulage nicht oder Suppe nicht bekommen.
David Boder: Was ist Zulage?
Irena Rosenwasser: Zulage war zum Brot. Jeden Abend haben wir bekommen ungefähr zwanzig (20) Deka Brot bekommen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und dazu war ein Stückchen Margarine oder ein Kaffeelöffel Marmelade oder ein Stückchen Salami oder so
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . das war Zulage
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Nicht immer
Irena Rosenwasser: aber doch...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war in Auschwitz
David Boder: Und das haben sie nicht gegeben?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . sie haben nicht gegeben, also man
David Boder: Ja, man war eben nicht sicher...
Irena Rosenwasser: Wenn sie nicht richtig gezählt, dann hat man uns bestraft dafür. Und der Block Älteste hat gesagt: „Kranke will ich nicht sehen.“ Warum und wieso, wenn jemand ist krank geworden, hat man sie nach Revier geführt.
David Boder: Aha. „Revier“ ist das Krankenhaus?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . ins Krankenhaus geführt und oft sind die Leute vom Revier nicht zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: In der Nacht hat man sie in einen schwarzen Wagen weg getragen, ohne Kleider und in das Krematorium. So war es besser „gesund“ zu sein, auch wenn man schon halb gestorben war.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nun haben wir angefangen zu arbeiten. Die erste Arbeit war für uns Ziegel holen von einem Lager bis zum Anderen. Das war ziemlich unangenehm. Vier Stück Ziegel so gerade halten in der Hand...
David Boder: Warum gerade?
Irena Rosenwasser: Da mussten wir halt und in Fünfer Reihe gehen, die Hände ausstrecken und so halten [unverständlich—beide sprechen]
David Boder: Wäre es nicht einfacher, die anders zu tragen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Gestapo hat das so verlangt, dass wir die so tragen.
David Boder: Das ist wie? Ausgestreckte Hände
Irena Rosenwasser: Ausgestreckte Hände und vier...
David Boder: Vier Ziegel.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . Ziegel.
David Boder: Und dann?
Irena Rosenwasser: Drei oder vier Mal.
David Boder: Und sie wurden aufgestellt in Reihen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Immer in Fünfer Reihe weil man musste die Leute zählen.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Immer wenn wir sind heraus von dem Lager gegangen, haben beim Tor die SS gezählt und aufgeschrieben.
David Boder: Aha. Nun...
Irena Rosenwasser: Und, hm, das war die erste Arbeit. Vier(4) Mal oder fünf (5) Mal spazieren in einer Reihe von einem Lager.
David Boder: Und für das war das?
Irena Rosenwasser: Weil die haben immer gebaut neue Blöcke, Block Häuser.
David Boder: Ja. Und man hat die Ziegel ohne welche Trage am Arm getragen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, nur in der...
David Boder: . . . mit ausgestreckten Händen getragen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Getragen...und ohne Schuhe, denn Schuhe haben wir überhaupt nicht gehabt. Oder hölzerne Schuhe und es war doch unmöglich gehen in diese großen hölzernen Schuhe.
David Boder: Und die Schuhe, die sie von zu Hause hatten?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die guten Schuhe hat man sofort weg genommen, umgetauscht im Bad.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ds war die einzige Sache, was sie haben erlaubt—die Schuhe. Aber die guten Schuhe haben sie...
David Boder: Weg genommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . weg genommen. Und es war immer so ein Kot in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ein [unverständlich—beide sprechen] immer Regen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Immer Regen. Und die Schuhe waren kaputt binnen zwei (2), drei (3) Tagen. Die hölzernen Schuhe auch, die waren...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . die waren auch kaputt.
David Boder: Und...
Irena Rosenwasser: Und das war die erste Arbeit. Und dann mussten wir auch täglich drei (3) Mal etwas holen von der Küche. In der Früh Kaffee, bloß Kaffee; mittags eine Suppe; abends Brot und Zulage. Das wars.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, davon konnte man nicht sterben eben, aber leben auch nicht.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das Lager war ziemlich sauber. Es waren...in erster Zeit waren keine Läuse und wir waren desinfiziert. Es war ein Entläusen ungefähr jedes Monat. Aber das war auch sehr schlecht gemacht,
David Boder: Warum?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . denn wir mussten stehen die ganze Nacht draußen und warten wie lange wir kommen herein ins Bad . Und dann wurden die Haare abgeschnitten und das war...
David Boder: Also beschreiben
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Kleider?
David Boder: Ja, die Kleider.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Kleider hat man desinfiziert wirklich.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie mir beschreiben, wie hat diese Entlausung ausgesehen, wie war das?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Entlausung war im Waschraum,...
David Boder: Ja, es war...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . in dem großen Waschraum—nicht in unserem Lager, sondern in Auschwitz, denn wir waren doch eigentlich in Birkenau—oben wo der Lager war.
David Boder: Sie waren in Birkenau?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja und unten da war Auschwitz auch, ein anderes Lager.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber wir waren auch in Auschwitz. Dort waren große Bäder für Desinfektion.
David Boder: Das waren nicht die selben Bäder, wo man die Leute vergast hat?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, nein.
David Boder: Aha, ja...
Irena Rosenwasser: Das waren nicht dieselben.
David Boder: Nun und dann...
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Kleider hat man sofort ausgezogen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: und man hat es herein getragen und man hat es desinfi...
David Boder: Desinfiziert.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . desinfiziert und...
David Boder: Womit?
Irena Rosenwasser: Mit einem Gas, den Namen weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Mit Gas?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das haben wir nicht gesehen, das haben auch Häftlinge gemacht...—die Männer.
David Boder: Ja. Aber man hat Ihnen Ihre selben Kleider zurück bekommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, nein...überhaupt nicht. Das war...
David Boder: Sie haben nicht zurück bekommen, was man gegeben hat? [beide sprechen]
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . was gerade gekommen ist.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wählen konnte man nicht.
David Boder: Ja. Für die eigenen Kleider hat man keine Nummern gehabt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Gar kein Eigenes, so was war nicht in Auschwitz. Die Nummer konnte man niemals auswählen, man bekam immer eine andere Nummer.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und dann sind die Kleider verschwunden auch, denn Einige sind gelaufen und haben mehrere Stücke bekommen und dann sind einige ohne Kleid geblieben und da hat man geschlagen alle—natürlich...dafür bekommt man es.
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: Nach der Desinfektion hat man auch die Decken desinfiziert
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und die Haare auch. Und das hat gedauert eine Nacht immer.
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und ohne Kleider sind wir gestanden...
David Boder: Wo?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . in der Früh in dem Baderaum, aber das war nie geheizt.
David Boder: Ah hm. Und das Wasser war kaltes Wasser?
Irena Rosenwasser: Oh, was war auch lauwarm, aber das hat zwei (2) Minuten gedauert.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir mussten schnell , sehr, sehr schnell...
David Boder: Waren das Bäder, Brausebäder oder was?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, Duschen.
David Boder: Nun? Hat man Seife dazu gegeben?
Irena Rosenwasser: Hat man etwas gegeben, sehr wenig, ungefähr für zwanzig (20) ein Stück Seife.
David Boder: Und was hat man getan? Haben sie sich untereinander eingeseift?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, das mussten wir.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und dann sind wir ins Lager zurück gekommen, da hat wieder der Appell angefangen. Zwei Mal am Tag—nachmittags war es bis abends, bis spät abends. Dann war ich froh, wenn man hat die Leute selektiert für Arbeit. Da in ich hinein in ein anderes Lager gekommen.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und dort ist mir gelungen in der Küche zu arbeiten. Da war ich in der Küche ungefähr vier Monate. Und das ganze Lager hat man ausgeleert, ungefähr zwei und dreißig tausend Leute. Wir wussten nicht, wohin diese Leute fahren, wohin sie gehen. Wir sind alleine in der Küche geblieben.
David Boder: Das heißt wieviel sind von ihnen geblieben? Es waren zwei und dreißig...
Irena Rosenwasser: In Birkenau waren so ungefähr zwei hundert (200), zwei hundert fünfzig (250,000) tausend.
David Boder: Und man hat zwei und dreißig tausend (32000) Leute ausgesucht...
Irena Rosenwasser: ausgesucht.
David Boder: und wohin hat man sie genommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Bessere Lager.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie hat man auf Transport, so hat man gesagt „auf Transport“ heraus geschickt von Auschwitz. Aber ich denke, sehr Wenige sind heraus gegangen...
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . wirklich von Auschwitz.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . die haben doch immer...
David Boder: Und die Krematorien waren in Birkenau oder in Auschwitz?
Irena Rosenwasser: In Birkenau vier (4), in Auschwitz auch.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, das war überall, überall.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und in die Schornsteine hat man immer gesehen...Feuer...
David Boder: Rauch.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, Rauch und Feuer...
David Boder: Und das Feuer von...von...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . hohe Feuer...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Hohe Flammen waren das.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich habe, zum Beispiel, eine Freundin gehabt im Spital, im Revier. Sie war schon gesund und am letzten Tag, weil sie wollte schon, sie hat gehofft sie kommt heraus vom Spital...hat man sie vergast. Das ganze Spital ausgeleert und ins Krematorium geschickt. Das war Auschwitz. Aber trotzdem sind Einige zurück gekommen, weil das war ein großes Theater.
David Boder: Was meinen Sie?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich denke es war so, so wie ein Theater, weil Einige hat man so ohne Füße, zum Beispiel, hier jemand hat einen Fuß gehabt...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und er ist am Leben geblieben. Der Mengele wollte zeigen, dass er lässt auch solche Leute leben. Es waren einige Kinder auch, ein Paar Stück...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . von allem war etwas...auch Einige hat man vom Spital zurück geschickt, also, dass wir sollen denken, dass unsere Eltern leben...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und unsere Geschwister leben, nur sie sind irgendwo in einem anderen...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . Lager. Wenn man zum Beispiel, ein Spital ausgeleert hat, hat er gesagt: „Ich führe diese Leute in ein Sanatorium, weil hier ist das Essen nicht gut...
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und die Luft auch nicht, so muss ich ihnen was Besseres geben.“
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und damit hat man die Leute nach Krematorium geführt.
David Boder: Ja aber die Krematorien waren doch gleich nahe bei und man hat es gewusst.
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, das hat man doch, wir haben doch das nie gesehen. Wir haben gesehen die Transporte gehen weg—wohin wir wissen nicht, es war immer Blocksperre.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Leute, wenn ein Transport ist weg gegangen, das ganze Lager war eingesperrt, in dem Block sein, dass wir wussten nichts.
David Boder: Nichts?
Irena Rosenwasser: Gar nichts, was hier geschieht,...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . wirklich...in Wirklichkeit. Und das war...da war ich in der Küche. Und die Küche war aufgelöst, das ganze Lager war aufgelöst...
David Boder: Wann war das?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war im Oktober.
David Boder: Welches Jahr?
Irena Rosenwasser: Vier und vierzig (44).
David Boder: Vier und vierzig (44)...ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Dann bin ich in ein anderes Lager gekommen. Ich habe gearbeitet wieder, denn ich wollte immer arbeiten, weil das war für mich das Beste.
David Boder: Welches Lager war das?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war...erst was es ein tschechisches Lager, von dort aus hat man die Tschechen alle ins Gas geführt. Wenn wir sind angekommen in Auschwitz...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: War es ein tschechisches Lager. Und nachher war es ganz leer. Und im Oktober...
David Boder: Waren es tschechische Juden oder nur Tschechen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Tschechische Juden. Tschechische Juden.
David Boder: Tschechische Juden, ja
Irena Rosenwasser: Ein Familienlager war es. Es war interessant. [lacht etwas]
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Frauen, Männer und Kinder waren zusammen...
David Boder: Waren Sie jemals in einem Familienlage>
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, ich war nicht.
David Boder: Aber Sie haben es gesehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, ich habe es gesehen. Aber diese Leute hat man selek...selektiert, die Alten, die Kinder hat man vergast.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja. Wir haben nur gehört, die Jungen sind auf Transport gefahren.
David Boder: Ja
Irena Rosenwasser: Tschechische Juden.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: So war das Lager leer. Dorthin sind wir herein von der Küche—hat man uns herüber geführt...
David Boder: In das tschechische Lager?
Irena Rosenwasser: In das tschechische Lager. Es war eine große Weberei auch in Auschwitz und da habe ich in der Weberei gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: So etwas Kriegsmaterial haben wir gewoben...gewebt.
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war nicht schwer, aber es war sehr ungesund, weil es war voll mit Staub, die...mit alte Lumpen haben wir gearbeitet.
David Boder: Oh, sie haben alte Lumpen ausgearbeitet?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und die Capos waren sehr schlecht—deutsche Prostituierte, Frauen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und sie haben immer geschimpft „Saujuden“. Sie haben uns sehr, sehr viel geschlagen.
David Boder: Und wie sind die Prostituierten dahin gekommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie waren die Capos, alles Verbrecher und Gigolos und Prostituierte, die waren...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . also, die wussten, sie waren oben. Weil sie konnten schlagen und töten und in Gas schicken. Auswählen auch für einige Leute, die werden ins Gas gehen; dann habe sie mit den SS Frauen und Männern gesprochen darüber.
David Boder: Ah hm...
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie waren nicht Juden; sie waren deutsche Arier. Also es waren viel polnische und deutsche Arische.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Auch Russische.
Irena Rosenwasser: Da waren wir sehr schlecht behandelt, aber in dieser Weberei haben wir Zulage bekommen. Das bedeutet wöchentlich ein halbes ( ½ ) Brot und etwas Zulage. Das war ein großer...[unverständlich—beide sprechen]
David Boder: Wieviel Brot?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ein halbes Brot, das ist so ungefähr vierzig (40) Deka Brot.
David Boder: Meinen Sie, vierzig (40) Deka Brot extra?
Irena Rosenwasser: Extra.
David Boder: Ja und?
Irena Rosenwasser: Eine Ration für die Arbeiter.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und Ende des Jahres hat man aufgelöst die Weberei und bin ich in das [unverständlich] Arbeitskommando gekommen beim Weichsel.
David Boder: Am Fluss? An der Weichsel?
Irena Rosenwasser: Am Fluss. Das war...
David Boder: Das war in Wisla, in Russisch.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war im Dezember
Irena Rosenwasser: Das Wetter ist sehr, sehr kalt im Dezember—überhaupt in Polen—und wir haben Erdarbeit, die schwerste Erdarbeit am Fluss gemacht.
David Boder: Was für eine Erdarbeit? Festigungen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Festigungen.
David Boder: Aha...Gruben?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und die...
David Boder: Ja und?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und die Erde war gefroren und wir haben mit große Hammer gearbeitet und mit Fuhren die Erde geschoben und das war fünf (5) Kilometer weit weg...
David Boder: Mit Fuhren? Das sind so kleine Wagen, nicht wahr?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja...aber das ist doch keine Arbeit für Frauen.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Überhaupt nicht für Frauen. Den ganzen Tag haben wir nichts gegessen, nur abends.
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wenn wir sind angekommen in dem Lager haben wir etwas Warmes bekommen. Die Schuhe waren sehr schlecht und fünf (5) Kilometer sind wir täglich gegangen und gekommen, also zehn (10) Kilometer.
David Boder: Aha. Und dann...
Irena Rosenwasser: Und immer „schnell, schnell los gehen“.
David Boder: Ist es wahr, man hat gesungen, wenn man ist gegangen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, wir haben nicht gesungen [lacht etwas], aber es sind Einige gekommen, die haben gesungen.
David Boder: Ah hm...
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir nicht. Es war Musik immer in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Von morgens in der Früh hat die Kapelle schon gespielt...
David Boder: Und...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und die Kommandos sind zur Arbeit gegangen.
David Boder: Und wer...? Ja? [beide sprechen]
Irena Rosenwasser: Und wenn man hat ins Krematorium geführt die Leute, hat auch die Musik immer gespielt...
David Boder: Wieso das?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . das Orchester. Darum sage ich, es war so wie ein Theater.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: So ungefähr wie in Nero’s Zeit.
David Boder: Ja, nun...?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war...
David Boder: Wer hat die Musik gespielt? Häftlinge?
Irena Rosenwasser: Häftlinge.
David Boder: Männer und Frauen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Männer und Frauen,...das war eine ziemlich günstige Stelle...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . in der Kapelle zu sein, weil die haben bessere Blöcke gehabt, bessere Kleider und auch Besseres zum Essen.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, was haben die im Laufe des Tages getan, wenn sie nicht gespielt haben?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das weiß ich nicht.
David Boder: Waren sie frei? Haben sie geprobt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Vielleicht ja,...geprobt.
David Boder: Und wer war der Dirigent?
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war interessant, weil man Konzert gegeben in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja, wieso?
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war ein Platz für die Häftlinge...und die Musik...die Kapelle hat schöne Konzerte für uns gegeben...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . anstatt Brot haben sie uns Musik gegeben.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war die schwerste Periode für mich in Auschwitz—im Außenkommando bei der Weichsel. Sehr viele Leute sind dort geblieben, die konnten nicht marschieren und gefroren auch.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ganz einfach erfroren, denn die Kleidung war nicht genügend und den ganzen Tag draußen sein ohne Essen oder Trinken. Viele, viel Leute sind dort gestorben. Auch die Gestapo haben mit Spaten tot geschlagen Einige. Wir haben mit Spaten gearbeitet und...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und wenn wir sind zu der Arbeit gekommen, konnten wir nicht schnell bewegen, sie hat uns an den Kopf geschlagen mit dem Spaten oder mit dem Hammer...
David Boder: Haben Sie das selbst gesehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, natürlich.
David Boder: Ein...
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich habe auch bekommen [lacht etwas], aber ich bin nicht gestorben.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber sie haben Andere geschlagen und...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . man hat die Leute, zum Beispiel, wenn wir sind angekommen, da war so ein Berg dort und da konnten wir nicht herunter gehen, weil es war doch...es war gefroren. Da hat man die Leute ganz einfach gestoßen.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und sie sind herunter gefallen, so sind wir angekommen...
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . zur Arbeit. Nachher hat man mich für „Transport“ ausgewählt. Das war immer sehr, sehr kompliziert...
David Boder: Was heißt „Transport“?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . weil wir wussten nicht, was das bedeutet.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: „Transport“—dass wir gehen weg von Auschwitz.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . irgend wo...
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und wir werden wieder arbeiten.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber manchmal hat das bedeutet Krematorium.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich war...acht (8) Mal war ich bei Selektion. Und Selektion hat bedeutet, wir waren ganz nackt und der Lagerarzt ist gekommen und hat uns angeschaut.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und der Rücken...also wenn wir haben nur das Kleinste an er Haut gehabt von Vitaminmangel...Vitaminausschläge, diese Leute wurden schon selektiert.
David Boder: Was heißt „Vitaminausschläge“?
Irena Rosenwasser: Vitaminausschläge bedeutet...
David Boder: Vitamin?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Nun Vitamine ist doch was Gutes!
Irena Rosenwasser: Vitamin...also Fehler, vitamin arm, avitaminos.
David Boder: Oh, avitaminos!!!
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Also, wenn es hat gezeigt, dass man keine Vitamine hat?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war...
David Boder: Also wie Beriberi, zum Beispiel.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, zum Beispiel, hm...
David Boder: Der Mund ist geschwollen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, geschwollen.
David Boder: Oder der Gaumen geschwollen. Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, die Zunge ist geschwollen...und die Füße, schreckliche, große Ausschläge.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Von Avitaminose.
David Boder: Kriegt man das von Avitaminose?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, das stimmt. Ich habe sehr viele gesehen und ich selbst habe auch etwas gehabt, aber nicht sehr gross.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Einige haben das am Rücken gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und der Wengele, der Lagerarzt ist gekommen und hat das gesehen. Und er hat sofort gesagt: „Das ist Krätze. Krätzige Leute extra.“
Irena Rosenwasser: Da war auch ein Krätze Block.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und Krätze Block hat man natürlich ins Krematorium geschickt und vergast.
Irena Rosenwasser: Man hat auch etwas gegeben gegen Krätze. Und das war so merkwürdig, dass man hat etwas Medikament gegeben und trotzdem hat man die Leute vergast.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Leute sollen denken, dass sie werden leben, dass sie am Leben bleiben...und nachher hat man...
David Boder: Vergast.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . vergast, ja.
David Boder: Nun dann?
Irena Rosenwasser: So bin ich...
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mal über diese Selektion. Und Sie sagen, sie waren in...
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja,...
David Boder: . . . acht Selektionen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Diese Selektionen...
David Boder: Das heißt, was hat man Ihnen gesagt,...was hat man annonciert? Was hat man gesagt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Der Block Älteste ist gekommen: “Oh, Mädchen, jetzt werdet Ihr...es wird eine sehr gute Arbeit sein...und ein guter Transport. Und alle sollt ihr euch melden für Transport, weil...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . das wird ausgezeichnet gut sein!“
Irena Rosenwasser: Dann war ein Zählappell wieder im Lager, ein besonderer Zählappell...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . ein neuer Zählappell und die SS Leute sind gekommen und haben die Leute angeschaut. Wenn es...
David Boder: Was heißt angeschaut? Heißt das Sie haben sich ausziehen müssen...ganz nackt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war...es war verschieden.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wenn es war Selektion für...für Krematorium, dann waren wir nicht ausgezogen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Da haben sie nur so angeschaut die Kranken, die Schwächeren, die mageren Leute. Die kamen heraus. Und dann mussten wir so eine Runde machen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Leute hat man nicht heraus gelassen...wieder gezählt und weg geführt. Und diese
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . waren für Gas bestimmt. Aber wenn man hat nackt selektiert die Leute, das heißt, dass man wirklich...wirklich zur Arbeit...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . da hat man mich zur Küche ausgewählt.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ganz nackt und nachher hat man Blutprobe genommen und verschiedene andere Dinge...
David Boder: Also die Frauen waren ganz nackt...und wer hat die Selektion gemacht?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ganz nackt und in die Hände haben wir so hoch gehalten...die eine Hand...
David Boder: Warum?
Irena Rosenwasser: So dass sie uns gut sehen von allen Seiten.
David Boder: Und wer war das? Waren das Frauen Ärzte?
Irena Rosenwasser: Der Lagerarzt...nein, nein, Männer! Es waren auch SS Frauen dabei.
David Boder: Aber wieviel Männer waren bei einer solchen...Selektion? Der Arzt und...
Irena Rosenwasser: Der Arzt und noch zwei (2) SS Männer . Nicht viele, zwei (2) oder drei (30).
David Boder: Aber die anderen SS Leute waren nicht Ärzte?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, überhaupt nicht, nur ganz einfache Soldaten.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir waren doch...
David Boder: [In English] Spool 63...Miss Irena Rosenwasser continues. Spool 62 has thirty-six minutes and has to be checked up.
David Boder: [In German] Also Fräulein Rosenwasser, Sie haben mir von der Selektion für die Arbeit erzählt...Wollen Sie mir das nochmal, wollen Sie uns das nochmal erzählen. Bitte sprechen Sie ein bisschen lauter.
Irena Rosenwasser: Selektion für Arbeit war so, dass die Leute mussten sich die Kleider ausziehen und die Selektion war nackt. Und wenn der Lagerarzt hatte...
David Boder: Und wenn der Lagerarzt...ja?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . hat die Leute stark und gesund gefunden, dann sind sie wirklich in ein Arbeitskommando gekommen. Und die Anderen sind noch im Lager geblieben und später hat man sie irgendwo hin transportiert.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Manchmal waren die Selektionen auch für ärztliche Zwecke. Also von stärkere Leute hat man Blut genommen...von stärkere Leute.
David Boder: Wozu das Blut? Für Transfusionen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Für Transfusionen und für deutsche Soldaten...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . also nicht für uns.
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war doch Krieg und sie...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . mussten doch Blut haben. Das war sehr schlimm, weil die haben nicht besseres Essen gegeben für die Leute, die haben Blut abgegeben.
David Boder: Haben Sie auch Blut gegeben?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein.
David Boder: Ja.
David Boder: Und dann?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und da hab ich ziemlich Angst gehabt am Ende des Jahres, was das bedeutet, ich bin in den Transport gekommen.
David Boder: Und?
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber das war ein wirklicher Transport. Am ein und zwanzigsten (21) Dezember hat man uns nach Bergen-Belsen geschickt.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Man hat uns etwas zu essen mit gegeben und SS Leute haben uns begleitet. Drei (3) Tage hat der Weg ge...ged...
David Boder: Gedauert.
Irena Rosenwasser: gedauert.
David Boder: Wo waren Sie? In was für Wagen waren Sie?
Irena Rosenwasser: Wieder in Viehwagen waren wir.
David Boder: In was für einem Monat des Jahres war es?
Irena Rosenwasser: Am ein und zwanzigsten (21) Dezember, es war nicht geheizt...
David Boder: Hat man Ihnen gesagt, warum Sie nach Bergen-Belsen gehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Es wurde überhaupt nicht gesagt, wohin wir gehen. Das hat man nie im Lager mitgeteilt.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Häftlinge wussten gar nicht, was das bedeutet.
David Boder: Waren sie Männer und Frauen oder nur Frauen alleine?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, nur Frauen.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: In Auschwitz waren die Frauen und Männer separiert. Sie waren nie zusammen, nur im...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . nur im Familienlager und dort war ich nicht.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir, wie haben sich, zum Beispiel, die Leute im Lager oder hier auf dem Transport betragen? Die Frauen zu einander? Waren die mehr oder weniger anständig? Wie...wie hat sich das entwickelt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Also, ein Mensch bleibt immer ein Mensch. Wer zu Hause ein guter Mensch war, der ist auch im Lager das geblieben. Aber...
David Boder: Das ist Ihre Meinung? Ja?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das ist meine Meinung. Aber Einige haben leider vergessen. Und die haben gesagt: „Ich hab [unverständlich], dass ich soll; es aufhalten—die Anderen interessieren mich nicht.“ Zum Beispiel unser Block Ältester hat gesagt: „Ich bin Schutzhäftling und mir kann gar nichts passieren. Aber Euch—seht Ihr den Rauch? Ich werd Euch alle hin schicken, ich werde...“
David Boder: War er Jude?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja. Sabotage machen, was bedeutet das, Sabotage? Wir durften nicht die Decke zerreißen, ein Stückchen nehmen, weil es war doch sehr kalt, unterhalb—unter dem Kleid oder...Wenn wir haben etwas nicht so gemacht, wie sie uns gesagt hatte, dann hat immer, immer gesagt, sie schickt uns ins Gas.
David Boder: Also man hat davon offen gesprochen, die haben vom Verbrennen gesprochen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie hat offen davon gesprochen und sie hat auch alte Frauen geschlagen und einmal hab ihr gesagt, wie kann sie so eine alte Frau schlagen, das kann doch meine Mutter oder ihre Mutter sein. Hat sie mich angeschaut und hat geantwortet: „Meine Mutter war auch vergast. Mir ist’s egal.“
David Boder: Ja, nun...?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und das waren Leute ohne Gefühl, hauptsächlich die, die in Positionen waren—die Block Ältesten, die Capos, die...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . die haben keine Skrupel mehr gehabt.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die waren schon im Lager drei (3), vier (4) Jahre, aber es waren sehr gute und sehr anständige Leute auch und die haben viel geholfen.
David Boder: Capos?
Irena Rosenwasser: Capos auch und...
David Boder: Andere.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . Andere.
David Boder: Nun? Und so sind Sie nach Bergen-Belsen gekommen. Bergen-Belsen ist wo?
Irena Rosenwasser: Bergen-Belsen ist näher, näher Hamburg, Hannover.
David Boder: In, hm, Nord Deutschland—Nordwest Deutschland.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir haben Glück gehabt beim Transport, weil wir nicht zu Fuß gingen, zu Fuß gegangen sind.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Andere haben den selben Weg in einer Woche gemacht...zu Fuß.
David Boder: Zu Fuß sind sie eine Woche gegangen, ja?
Irena Rosenwasser: Zu Fuß. Und sehr viele wurden abgeschossen, die konnten nicht gehen. Sie sind hinten hin geblieben, da haben die SS gesagt: „ Wenn ihr könnt nicht gehen, dann...“
David Boder: Schießen wir.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . schießen wir. Und sie haben wirklich sehr Viele abgeschossen. Wir sind angekommen nach drei (3) Tagen in Bergen-Belsen, nach Bergen...und von der Stadt Bergen sind wir zu Fuß ins Lager Belsen gegangen. Dort war—scheinbar was es nicht so schlimm und nicht so schlecht, wenn wir sind angekommen. Ich habe gedacht, hier wird es viel besser sein, als in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wirklich, es war keine Disziplin und in den ersten Tage war kein Zählappell...
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war eine...wirklich eine Überraschung für uns, aber es war auch keine Disziplin und das war sehr schlimm, denn das Lager war voll Schmutz.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und am dritten (3.) Tag habe ich schon Läuse bekommen und Läuse gesehen überall. Und das Essen war immer schlimmer und weniger.
David Boder: In welchem Jahr war das.
Irena Rosenwasser: Fünf und vierzig (45) im Januar.
David Boder: Also die Russen sind schon gekommen nach Auschwitz.
Irena Rosenwasser: Nach Auschwitz. Von Auschwitz hat man...Einige sind dort geblieben. Die Russen haben doch Einige befreit in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber wir sind heraus von Auschwitz.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und wir haben zerstört die Krematorien bevor.
David Boder: Wer hat sie zerstört?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Häftlinge in Auschwitz. Es waren Krematorien, wo [unverständlich—beide sprechen]
David Boder: [unverständlich—beide sprechen]
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . man hat immer Kommando zusammengestellt, ich war einen Tag...einen Tag habe ich dort gearbeitet, habe ich die Ziegel getragen und habe Holz getragen und habe gesehen richtig, wie das ausgeschaut hat.
David Boder: Nun warten Sie mal. Sie haben einen Tag im Krematorium gearbeitet. Wann?
Irena Rosenwasser: Wenn ich war im Transport Block.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Dann hat man uns jeden Tag für eine wenige Arbeit heraus geführt vom Lager...es war im Dezember.
David Boder: Ja. Kalt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, kalt war es. Aber das Krematorium Kommando—zerstören das Krematorium—war nicht das schlimmste Kommando.
David Boder: Oh, Sie hatten das Krematorium zu zerstören?
Irena Rosenwasser: Zerstört.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir haben doch gar nichts gesehen. Nur wie es war, sie haben alles, hm, angeschrieben. Zum Beispiel: „Zur Desinfektion,...
David Boder: Ja
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . “ „Zum Baderaum“. Die Leute wussten überhaupt nicht, was dort geschieht. Die haben geglaubt, das ist ein Bad.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Für Kleider waren Bänke, Spiegel waren sogar drinnen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Man hat für die Leute Handtuch gegeben, hat man erzählt...das Krematorium Kommando...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und es waren ganz kleine Gaskammern und da hat man herein gestoßen die Leute und das waren Dusch, Dusch, Duschen und von den Duschen ist kein Wasser gekommen.
David Boder: Ja...hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und nachher, wenn man hat geöffnet die Türe haben, das war doch Krematorium Kommando—Krematorium Kommando, die haben diese halbtoten Leute heraus geschleppt, die Haare abgeschnitten, die goldenen Zähne heraus gerissen...
David Boder: Was heißt halbtote Leute?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie waren noch nicht ganz vergast—sie waren noch nicht ganz...
David Boder: Wer hat das gesagt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das haben wir selbst gehört von die Männer, die haben im Krematorium Kommando gearbeitet.
David Boder: So hat man die halbtoten Leute heraus genommen und die Haare abgeschnitten?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Haar geschnitten...
David Boder: Aber Sie haben mir gesagt, die Haare hat man vorher abgeschnitten.
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber die, die ins Krematorium gegangen sind, die waren doch nicht im Bad. Das war doch im Bad.
David Boder: Ah!
Irena Rosenwasser: Das hat ja so ausgeschaut, wie ein Bad, aber das war das Krematorium.
David Boder: Ja, und da hat man...
Irena Rosenwasser: Da hat man sofort vom Bahnhof...
David Boder: . . . ins Krematorium gebracht.
Irena Rosenwasser: Oder vom Lager, nach der Selektion ins Krematorium geführt. Das war das Tägliche...immer haben sie...
David Boder: Und den toten Leuten haben sie die Haare abgeschnitten.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Haare und die goldenen Zähne...
David Boder: Wer hat das gezogen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Diese...vom Sonderkommande die Häftlinge, leider.
David Boder: Und sie mussten das abgeben?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die mussten das machen und die SS war natürlich überall. Die SS haben nicht gearbeitet, nur die Häftlinge haben...
David Boder: Und was haben sie mit den Haaren getan?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Haare hat man benützt für Kriegsmaterial. Ich weiß nicht...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . für Stoffe oder etwas hat man daraus gemacht.
David Boder: Ja und?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und nachher hat man sie verbrannt und entweder drinnen in vier (4) Krematorien, weil die waren doch da sehr große, hm,...
David Boder: Ofen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, Ofen oder draußen in Grab, Gräbern.
David Boder: Aber hat man die nicht zuerst tot gemacht?
Irena Rosenwasser: Dafür hat man doch keine Zeit eigentlich gehabt. Transporte sind ununterbrochen gekommen und die haben den ganzen Tag gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die haben nicht viel geschaut...
David Boder: Ja, und...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . wie weit die tot sind. Also einen Tag haben wir dort gearbeitet, dann haben wir es zerstört.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Im Dezember war es, wenn die Russen sind gekommen. Holz haben von dort wir genommen in das Lager gebracht.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die wollten doch alles...
David Boder: Man sollte nichts sehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Man sollte nichts sehen. Es sind nur ein oder zwei (2) Krematorien gewesen für wirkliche Tote.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Also ich habe Ihnen erzählt wir sind in Belsen angekommen.
Irena Rosenwasser: In den ersten Tagen...in den ersten Tage war es nicht so schlimm, aber nachher habe ich gesehen, Auschwitz war vielleicht in einigen Beziehungen sogar besser. Vor allen Dingen war es da sauberer und keine Läuse. Das Essen war nicht genügend, aber man konnte nicht davon sterben. Belsen war noch viel, viel schlimmer. Brot ungefähr—einmal, zwei Mal in der Woche hat man kein Brot gegeben. Das war die Strafe und immer dünner und dünnere Stücke. Und die Suppe, von der Suppe war immer weniger. Das Lager war, wie man sagt, verlaust; es war voll mit Läusen und Scheiße. Es waren keine richtigen Arbeitskommandos, die Leute haben nicht gearbeitet und er Typhus hat begonnen. Ich war dort, es war auch eine Weberei...
David Boder: Haben Sie Anti-Typhus Injektionen bekommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: In Auschwitz hab ich—in der Küche, weil ich war in der Küche, haben sie mir...
David Boder: Da haben Sie eine Typhus Injektion bekommen, ja?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und ich habe wieder in der Weberei gearbeitet, weil ich konnte nicht liegen den ganzen Tag auf dem Bett und schauen, wie die Leute sterben. Da bin ich in die Weberei gegangen arbeiten, aber ich konnte es in der Weberei nicht aushalten, weil die Leute immer mehr und mehr krank geworden sind.
David Boder: In Belsen.
Irena Rosenwasser: In Belsen. Dann hat man das Lager auf zwei (2) Teile separiert—die Gesunden...
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . eine Unterteilung die Kranken.
Irena Rosenwasser: Hier war kein Krematorium. Es war ein Krematorium, aber nur für die Toten.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber es war nicht nötig. Ich denke, hier sind eben so viele Leute gestorben, als in Auschwitz, wo man hat die Leute vergast. Den ganzen Tag haben wir bei Weberei gesehen, die großen, großen Frachtwagen voll mit Tote. Es war nicht zugedeckt, so ein Kutscher ist mit einem Pferd also gekommen...
David Boder: Mit einem Pferd?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja und hat geführt in das Krematorium verbrennen, die waren tot.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wirklich tot. Und nachher ist die Lager Älteste von Auschwitz gekommen und hat sie Zähl-Appell geordnet...für die Halb-Toten...Zähl-Appell...
David Boder: Wer war das?
Irena Rosenwasser: [unverständlich], auch eine Slowakin...hat sie geheißen.
David Boder: Haben Sie die Frau, die nachher in Bergen Belsen verurteilt wurde, gekannt? Irene...Irma Grese?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, ja, ja...Irma Grese...
David Boder: . . . Irma Grese.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und Kramer, der war unser Lager Kommandant
David Boder: Haben Sie Irma...gekannt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Grese.
David Boder: Grese?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, ich habe von ihr Schläge manchmal bekommen!
David Boder: Wollen Sie die Frau beschreiben; man kriegt so Verschiedenes von ihrem Aussehen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Also Irma Grese war ziemlich jung, ich denke so ein und zwanzig (21) Jahre alt. Sie war blond, eine Germanin, sehr schön war sie.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wie eine Schauspielerin.
David Boder: War sie gross gewachsen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, sie war nicht gross...ungefähr hundert zwei und sechzig (162)...
David Boder: Pfund?
Irena Rosenwasser: Hundert zwei und sechzig (162) Zentimeter...
David Boder: Hundert zwei und sechzig (162) Zentimeter...
Irena Rosenwasser: Zentimeter, ja, gross.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, und sie war immer sehr nett angezogen...
David Boder: Was sie höher, als Sie sind?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ungefähr so hoch wie ich.
David Boder: Ja, und...?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und immer mit Peitsche und Revolver...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . herum gegangen im Lager. Und natürlich hat sie geschaut, wo sie kann etwas finden und wo sie kann schlagen.
David Boder: Warum ist das so natürlich?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie war eine wirkliche Sadistin.
David Boder: Hat sie einen Hund mit gehabt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Hunde, ja die SS haben doch immer große, sehr schöne Hunde gehabt. Und sie ist auch oft mit Hunden gekommen und Einige haben auch große Bisse davon. Ich habe, Gott sei Dank, keine im Lager bekommen. Hauptsächlich bei der Arbeit hat man die Hunde auf die Leute...
David Boder: Gehetzt.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . ja, gehetzt
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Also die Irma Grese war wirklich furchtbar. Bei allen Selektionen hat sie teilgenommen. Sie hat ausgewählt die Leute fürs Krematorium.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Was kann ich von ihr sagen? Ich denke, sie war so eine Fana,...Fana...Fanatist...
David Boder: Eine fanatische Natur.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, ein fanatischer Nazi, im Hitlerismus, und sie hat auch militärische Auszeichnungen gehabt.
David Boder: Aha, hat sie manchmal Reden gehalten?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nicht große Reden.
David Boder: Was hat sie gewöhnlich gesagt?
Irena Rosenwasser: „Sport“ hat sie mit uns oft gemacht...sporthafte Leute darf...wir mussten große, schwere Steine nehmen und laufen damit und wenn wir dann nicht schnell genug gelaufen sind, hat sie mit der Peitsche geschlagen. Das war unser Sport...knien und aufstehen...mit große, schwere Steine.
David Boder: Knien mit den Steinen und aufstehen?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und laufen dann damit...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und das war [unverständlich] Lage.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und...sie hat doch immer Stiefel getragen und mit den Stiefeln hat sie die Leute getreten.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das Blut ist immer geronnen im Lager...von der Nase oder von den Ohren, von irgendwo...die haben doch geschlagen...nicht einfach, sondern sie haben so geschlagen, das Blut musste immer rinnen.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war die Irma Grese. Kramer war ein großer, dicker Mann, immer mit der Zigarre. Er war nicht so oft im Lager, aber wenn er ist gekommen, haben wir immer Strafe bekommen.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel?
Irena Rosenwasser: Meistens kein Essen, das war die größte Strafe.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . kein Essen. Die Blöcke waren nicht sauber, hat er gesagt, oder außerhalb war keine Ordnung, die Leute haben nicht schön marschiert in Fünfer-Reihen, nicht stramm marschiert und wir haben bekommen Strafe dafür, hm
Irena Rosenwasser: In Belsen hat der Kramer eine große Rede gehalten, dass wir werden befreit sein.
David Boder: Wann?
Irena Rosenwasser: In kurzer Zeit, ungefähr im Jänner.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und dass wir sollen folgen der Lager Ältesten...
David Boder: Hm.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und die Freiheit kommt schon. Die Irma Grese hat uns selbst gesagt, wenn die Engländer waren schon sehr nah...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . dass: „Ich war zu Euch gut, ist das wahr?“
Irena Rosenwasser: und „Wir werden alle befreit werden von den Engländern.“ hat sie gesagt.
David Boder: Oh, das hat sie gesagt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich bin froh, ich bin sehr froh. Häftlinge sind gekommen und haben es uns erzählt.
David Boder: Dass die Engländer kommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja und dann wollte sie sehr freundlich und gut sein zu uns.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann?
Irena Rosenwasser: Und so habe ich gearbeitet in der Weberei. Und die Weberei wurde aufgelöst, weil die Leute waren immer krank. Und in meinem Block—ich bin in einen schrecklichen Block geraten, wo tausend Leute waren ohne Betten, nur bloß am Fußboden gelegen mit Toten zwischen Lebendigen. Essen war nichts und die Läuse waren sehr schlimm, diese Läuse waren—überall waren Läuse. Und ich habe gesehen, es kommt das Ende, wenn nicht kommt eine schnelle Hilfe. Ich war—zum Letzten—war ich im sogenannten Totenkommando. Das war das furchtbarste Kommando, was man im Leben haben kann.
David Boder: Was war das.
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Toten mussten wir den ganzen Tag vom Block heraus schleppen. Täglich waren so ungefähr zwanzig (20) bis fünf und zwanzig (25) Tote und wir mussten...es war ein großer Berg, man hat nie begraben können die Toten, es waren so viele, große Berge,...
David Boder: Bisschen lauter.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . mussten wir in andere Lager herüber schleppen die Toten, vier (4) oder (5) Leute. Wir waren auch sehr, sehr schwach.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber trotzdem haben wir dafür doppelte Suppe bekommen.
David Boder: Oh, Sie haben extra Suppe bekommen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und wenn wir wollten leben, müssen wir das machen. Es war nämlich im Lager zwei Wochen kein Wasser. Nachher war schon keine Butter. Etwas Suppe war noch.
David Boder: Warum war kein Wasser?
Irena Rosenwasser: Es war, weil sie haben gesagt, das Wasser macht den Typhus und darum sperren sie ab alles Wasser.
David Boder: So was kann man trinken?
Irena Rosenwasser: Trinken überhaupt nicht, das eben war sehr traurig, meine Freundinnen sind neben mir gestorben und haben mich gebittet: „Irinka, bring mir Wasser, bring mir Wasser.“, weil die haben ein und vierzig (41) und zwei und vierzig (42) Grade Fieber gehabt...
David Boder: Das war im Block, nicht im Revier?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die waren schon alle im Block. Das Revier war...überall vor all den Blöcken waren heraus geschmissen zwanzig (20), dreißig (30) Tote. Also es war keine Ordnung mehr, Brot war schon...es hat überhaupt kein Brot gegeben, nur ein bisschen Suppe, die tranken wir...
David Boder: Nachdem Sie die Toten raus getragen haben, haben Sie sich waschen können?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, das war eben, dass wir haben mit diese Hände gegessen und ohne Wasser. Es war überhaupt kein Wasser. Einige vom Totenkommande sind gestorben natürlich von Infektion. Und so...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . also man hat Glück gehabt, so zum Beispiel, wie ich, ich bin am Leben geblieben. Die Stärksten und die Schönsten sind gestorben. Ich habe eine Freundin gehabt, achtzehn (18) Jahre alt, wir waren in Auschwitz und überall zusammen und in Bergen-Belsen ist sie gestorben...einen Tag vor der Befreiung. Nach der Befreiung war die Lage auch nicht besser geworden, weil...
David Boder: Warum?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . weil die, die Okkupations-Truppen haben Essen gebracht, aber Militäressen, Konserven, die sind schwer...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Fette Suppe. Die Leute waren sehr ausgehungert und habe schnell gegessen und dann sind sie noch kranker geworden. Ich denke, dass nach der Befreiung noch dreißig tausend (30000) Leute sind gestorben...nach der Befreiung.
David Boder: Nach der Befreiung?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Wie viel schätzen Sie waren denn im Ganzen in Belsen?
Irena Rosenwasser: In Belsen...in Belsen, kann man nicht...kann man überhaupt nicht schätzen, weil von alle Lager hat man nach Belsen gebracht die Leute. Und sehr Viele sind gestorben, aber täglich sind neue Transporte gekommen, so kann man das überhaupt nicht...
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . schätzen...
David Boder: Aber zu einer Zeit wieviel Leute hat Belsen gehabt...zu gewisser Zeit?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das weiß ich nicht genau.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir waren überhaupt...wir wussten nicht...wir konnten das überhaupt nicht begreifen, dass die Engländer kommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir waren alle so krank...ich war auch krank, ein und vierzig Fieber habe ich gehabt...
David Boder: Oh, Sie waren auch krank?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, aber ich bin nicht gelegen...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . einen Moment bin ich nicht gelegen. Es ist interessant, ich weiß, dass ich krank war, erstens meine Freundin hat mir gesagt, sie kann neben mir nicht schlafen, weil ich so heiß war. Meine Haare sind mir nachher ausgefallen und alle die Typhus gehabt haben, haben die Haare verloren.
David Boder: Ah hm...nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Wer einmal sich gelegt hat ist nie mehr aufgestanden. Die Läuse haben sie lebend gegessen.
David Boder: Nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nun waren wir befreit.
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir, wie ist diese Befreiung gegangen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir haben nicht viel bemerkt von der Befreiung. Wir sind nicht viel herum gegangen. Überall der Weg war voll mit Tote. Sie sind gesessen mit ihrer kleinen—wie heißt das...Schüssel...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . für Suppe und so sind sie gestorben.
David Boder: Und so sind sie gestorben mit der Schüssel Suppe.
Irena Rosenwasser: Da waren sie...niemand hat sie begraben, niemand hat sie getragen...
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . so spazieren wir durch das Lager, wir waren alle so apathisch die Befreiung hab ich bemerkt, denn die Deutschen waren nicht mehr am Tor.
David Boder: Sie sind verschwunden?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie sind verschwunden. Und einige Soldaten, so ungarische Soldaten, die in Deutschland waren, sind mit weisem Band gekommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Da hab ich einen Soldaten gefragt, warum er hat ein weißes Band...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . da hat er gesagt, er weiß überhaupt nichts.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Wir wussten nichts. Nur dann wussten wir, wenn wir fahren haben gesehen die Engländer in Uniform, mit Panzer...
David Boder: Sie sind herein gekommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie sind herein gekommen. Ich erinnere mich, ich habe gesehen den Lager Kommandanten Kramer mit , ich glaube der Name war Eisenhower—ich erinnere mich nicht bestimmt—der hat gezeigt für die Herren. Er ist beim Auto gestanden und hat sein, seine Arbeit gezeigt.
David Boder: Kramer?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die Millionen Toten. Ja, der Kramer. Er hat gesagt, er wollte helfen, aber er hat keine Mittel gehabt und da konnte er nicht mehr machen.
David Boder: Sie haben ihn aber...Oh ja, Kramer wurde nachher gehängt.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, in Lüneburg war der Prozess.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Gese und Kramer waren dort und einige SS wurden erhängt.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Irena Rosenwasser: Das war die Befreiung. Nachher sind die Engländer gekommen und haben uns wirklich desinfiziert, nicht so wie in Auschwitz, sondern mit einem Pulver, das [unverständlich—Rauschen im Tonband]...
David Boder: Ja, mit DDT.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und die Kranken, die Schwerkranken...
David Boder: Was haben sie getan? Das Pulver mit einem...
Irena Rosenwasser: So mit einer...
David Boder: Mit Pumpen.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja. Es war sehr angenehm. Die Läuse sind sofort verschwunden. Nachher sind sie wieder gekommen und sie haben uns wieder gegeben das...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . das Pulver. Und so war es von Tag zu Tag besser, ist es besser geworden. Ach, ich kann gar nicht erzählen den Umstand der im Lager war. Da waren keine Toiletten. Alles war draußen am Hof, der ganze Block war in so, weil bei Typhus, damit hat man einen schrecklichen Durchfall.
David Boder: Ja. Was für ein Typhus war das? Magentyphus oder Flecktyphus?
Irena Rosenwasser: Beide.
David Boder: Beide Typhus. Und der Durchfall und da waren keine Toiletten?
Irena Rosenwasser: Keine Toiletten. Und der Block war voll damit und der Hof und alles, alles.
David Boder: Und wer hat das dann ausgeräumt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Die SS Leute. Die Engländer haben die SS gebracht und die haben Ordnung gemacht und die haben nachher die Toten geschleppt und nicht wir, nicht das Toten Kommando...
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . wir waren ja auch halb tot [lacht etwas].
David Boder: Haben Sie mit den SS gesprochen, wie war das dann?
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein, nein. Die Leute vom Lager haben Steine geworfen, aber die Engländer haben gesagt, das ist nicht unsere Sache.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und die SS Frauen haben gearbeitet nachher,das haben wir gesehen. Und die haben die Toten...
David Boder: Aufgeräumt?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . aufgeräumt. Und es ist ein Friedhof, ein sehr großer Friedhof in Bergen-Belsen. Und wir waren transportiert in ein anderes Lager, ein neues Lager, wo die SS eigentlich haben gewohnt. Große Gebäude, gesundheitliche Gebäude mit Fenstern.
David Boder: Bei Bergen-Belsen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Neben...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Neben Bergen. Das war schon viel, viel besser. Eine grössere Küche...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . eine grössere Küche und dann haben wir Kleider bekommen und Lebensmittel...
David Boder: Wer hat das gebracht?
Irena Rosenwasser: American Joint Committee war dort, jüdische Relief und dass britische Rote Kreuz und verschiedene große Welt Organisationen. Die haben für alle Leute Kleiderstücke gegeben, die besten, gute,...das Beste zum Essen.
David Boder: Nun haben Sie schon Betten für sich gehabt? [lacht etwas]
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja, all. Eine Person in einem Bett.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Aber leider sind Viele, Viele nachher gestorben von Schwäche. Sie konnten nicht...sie waren, zum Beispiel, Einige waren fünf und zwanzig (25) Kilo. Ich habe fünf und dreißig (5) gewogen, jetzt bin ich fünf und fünfzig (55), da hab ich zwanzig (20) Kilo zugenommen.
David Boder: Nun, Sie sehen nicht zu dick aus! [lacht]
Irena Rosenwasser: Nein. [lacht]
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, wo...wohin sind Sie dann von Bergen-Belsen gegangen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich hab gearbeitet.
David Boder: Wo?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich war mit [unverständlich] British Post Office, ich spreche doch etwas English
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und Französisch, so verschiedene Sprachen und...
David Boder: Und haben die für die Arbeit gezahlt?
Irena Rosenwasser: Sie haben etwas in diese Mark, diese...
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . Militär Mark bezahlt. Und wir haben Zigaretten bekommen und Pakete, diese Karitas-Pakete. Und es war recht angenehm und schöne Arbeit war es überhaupt für diese Leute die Briefe weiter schicken. Mit Militär Post haben wir das...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . gemacht.
David Boder: . . . getan
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . getan.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann?
Irena Rosenwasser: Da war ich in Bergen-Belsen und habe dort gearbeitet bis Oktober. Und dann im Oktober mit American Joint Konvoi bin ich von Bergen-Belsen durch Belgien und dann nach Paris gekommen.
David Boder: Warum sind Sie nicht nach Ungarn zurück gegangen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Weil ich wusste, dass ich habe dort nichts mehr...
David Boder: Ein bisschen lauter...sie wussten...
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . dass ich leider nicht [unverständlich] habe, weil meine Brüder waren fesche, junge Leute...und wir wussten schon...ich war doch in Belsen vom zum fünfzehnten (15) April und dann waren wir befreit...bis Oktober...und da habe ich keine Nachricht bekommen...und Viele sind von Ungarn zurück gekommen. Die waren in Ungarn und sind auch zurück gekommen.
David Boder: Das heißt sie sind von Belsen nach Ungarn gegangen und warum sind sie zurück gekommen?
Irena Rosenwasser: Weil die haben niemanden gefunden und haben nur schreckliche Sorgen gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Schwierigkeiten und Sorgen und sie haben gedacht, sie werden auswandern, aber von einem Lager ist es...
David Boder: Leichter?
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . leichter.
David Boder: Und dann wie sind Sie...
Irena Rosenwasser: Und dann wenn sie zurück kommen, dann habe ich sofort geschrieben und Nachrichten bekommen, dass leider niemand ist zu Hause von meiner Familie.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und da hat es für mich keinen Zweck gehabt zurück zu kehren, denn ich will auch auswandern nach Amerika und haben ein Affidavit schon seit Belsen...
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . bekommen nach Amerika und damit bin ich nach Paris gekommen.
David Boder: Oh, das war...[beide sprechen]
Irena Rosenwasser: . . . und nach einer Woche...
David Boder: . . . zum ersten Mal in Frankreich?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich war noch nie in Frankreich. Nach einer Woche hab ich ein employ...also eine Stelle hier bei Joint bekommen und seit dann arbeite ich hier.
David Boder: Aha.
Irena Rosenwasser: Und ich warte auf meine Emigration.
David Boder: Und Sie gehen nach Los Angeles?
Irena Rosenwasser: Ich hoffe es.
David Boder: Dann müssen Sie meine Tochter aufsuchen, sie ist Doktor there.
Irena Rosenwasser: Aha.
David Boder: Und ihr Mann ist Doktor. Sie ist Dr. Boder.
Irena Rosenwasser: Boder.
David Boder: Mein Name ist Boder auch.
Irena Rosenwasser: Können Sie mir vielleicht die Adresse geben?
David Boder: Und sie geben mir Ihre Adresse.
Irena Rosenwasser: Ja.
David Boder: [In English] Also...this completes the interview with Miss Irena Rosen...Rosenwasser, Spool sixty three (63). The beginning is on Spool sixty two (62). Paris, August 22nd, 1946. Hm, would you say it in English, your address, the address of your uncle in Los Angeles. Would you say that?
Irena Rosenwasser: Rabbiner Goldberger, two thousand four hundred seventeen [unintelligible] Street, Los Angeles forty three (43), California.
David Boder: Aha. Alright.